[Music]
I know y'all can't handle this [ __ ]
I know y'all gonna flag this [ __ ]
video like you always do and I have to
call Google and be like hey they flagged
another one
yeah my ad my fan base is basically a
bunch of [ __ ] oh this video had blood
in it oh this video had nipples in it
boo this video was a little bit too
sexual
ooh he may be swirl excuse me why don't
you just go to the [ __ ] Australia
like the good old days what do you bet
you even flagged this video already
because you're triggered by my glasses
you're all a bunch of wimps
don't like [ __ ] video all right stop
flying the video I'm sick and tired of
this [ __ ] shake can you all stop
flagging my [ __ ] videos stop flagging
the videos god damn it I don't make any
money if you flag the video what do you
think I'd do this for free do you think
I'm some kind of [ __ ] charity do you
think I do this for fun do you think I
do YouTube for fun are you don't lean it
for the money [ __ ] you for even thinking
that all right now I gotta make this
video and it'd be great if you don't
[ __ ] flag it alright don't flag the
video so if you're not up for the
challenge
[ __ ] then click the [ __ ] away and don't
flag the video man I should be a rapper
that was pretty good
videos cuz I'm better than you I'm a
virgin cheers over speakers on alert
kids locked in my basement get to the
surface never show my face keyboard is a
fortress king of the Internet you better
get reporting you person's a [ __ ] which
is visited [ __ ] if this is offensive
you don't have to listen to
computer do something productive you
can't service people it covers and
nothing you hiding behind insecurities
we human beings have breathing maturity
[ __ ] your opinion is that's it don't
mean nothing to me just pick that
dislike and move on with your life